uh the subcommittee is to consider an
application to vary the premises license
for the big sheet
in attendance the council's lead
licensing officer chris clark house
um the council solicitor damian hunter
environmental protection officer matthew
menocho
public health and housing manager janet
williams democratic services officer tom
brownstone
and kesley i will now establish whether
the council's sitting have a personal
prejudice
prejudicial interest in the matter
before us
okay oh now now ask the applicants to
identify themselves together with any
representative
or witnesses
[Music]
thank you right
i'll now establish if any responsible
authorities also
yes we have nutmeg from environmental
protection
oh now establish which objectives or
their representatives are present please
give your name and address and say
whether it is a personal objection or
made on behalf of others
and whether you wish to speak
what are you doing
speaking on behalf of myself and foreign
[Music]
my mother and the business philosophy
[Music]
yeah i'll be phillips
from morton house hamilton road speaking
on
myself my wife and
[Music]
okay all right i will now run through
the procedure as we follow
today's hearing after an introduction by
the lead licensing officer
the applicant will be invited to present
their case to the panel and call any
witnesses as necessary
the objectives for their representatives
will then have their opportunity to
present their case the applicant will be
allowed
the right final reply after all the
evidence has been referred
this hearing will take the form of a
discussion led by me as the chairman
and all points and questions should
therefore be put through me
the purpose of the hearing is to
consider the facts and to hear the
evidence to enable the panel
to make a fair decision
the regulations require that the
applicant is awarded an equal amount of
time
for that given to the objectives i would
ask that all parties try to keep to a
maximum of 15 minutes on given evidence
objectives and the applicants may ask
questions of each other
and the witnesses after they have given
evidence with my permission
that not a cross-examination of
traditional sense will not be permitted
questions should be put impartially
through myself the panel may refuse to
permit evidence that is
irrelevant or repetitious at the
conclusion i will adjourn and
the hearing to allow the panel to retire
and seek advice from our solicitor
i expect to be able to give the decision
and the reasons for it at the conclusion
of this theory
all papers have been reread by the
subcommittee so we are familiar
with the issues relating to the
application there are a few
new ones but we'll come to those
right submission major party i will ask
the lead licensing officer to present
this report
thank you chair um first of all before i
present my report i'd just
like to say um we've had some additional
submissions
um into two of them are in support of
the application
and two of them are in support against
the application this normal procedure to
allow these
but we need to make every party aware
that this is the case they are
single page submissions now i've got
copies here if anybody would like those
copies but is anybody in objection to
allowing the additional submissions
fine okay so share you're allowed to
include those submissions as part of
your configurations thank you
i'll now i'll now present my report um
an application for a variation to the
premises license for the big sheep
united action
has been made to torres district council
in accordance with the licensing act
2003.
the licensing authority has received
relevant representations about the
application
and in accordance with section 35 free
of the act
the application must now be determined
by a subcommittee of the vice
the council's licensing committee at a
licensing hearing
is located between billy ford and
habitsham on habits road
adjacent to the a39 a map has been
provided to
the panel detailing the location and
proximity
to the development apprentices from the
injections
the big sheep has held a premises
license for the sale of alcohol since
the introduction of the licensing act
back in 2005.
in 2020 due to the coronavirus pandemic
mr turner reviewed his business model
and sought to provide live
music venue it was agreed that this
would be covered by a minor variation
on a time limited basis up to the 30th
of september
2020. a meeting was held
on the 1st of april to determine mr
turner's plans for 2021
he was advised that a full variation
would be required if he wished to
continue with the dying music events
therefore a full variation of
application was submitted to the council
on the 21st of april 2021
the closing date for a seat of
representations was the 19th of may
2021 20 objections were received
the hearing regulations allow the local
authority to extend the time limit
required for a hearing to be held for a
specified period
where it considers this is to be
necessary in the public interest
following consultation with the
council's legal team and the chair of
the licensing committee
it was decided it would be in the public
interest to allow this to turn into
whole
forthcoming events for these events mr
turner would be required to employ an
independent noise consultant
to undertake monitoring of the noise
levels the council would also undertake
noise monitoring
these events would enable the gallery of
essential noise data in order to inform
a more robust
noise management plan
it would also allow the subcommittee to
receive specific
non-specific noise data from live events
to enable them to make a more informed
decision when considering the
application
the noise management plan and noise
monitoring data has been provided to the
subcommittee
in the agenda
in summary the application was for the
provision of regulated
regulated entertainment on the whole
site both indoors and outdoors
specifically plays and films on monday
to sunday
from 10 00 in the morning to 10 in the
evening
boxing and wrestling on friday to sunday
from 10 to
10 and live music recording music
and performance of dance on friday
saturday back holidays
from 10 till 10 and sunday
from 10 to 6.
a copy of the application and the
proposed conditions
are detailed in appendix saving report i
won't go through them in detail now
respect the comments received from the
responsible authorities um comments were
received from the environmental
protection officer from torres district
council
there were no other representations from
any of the other responsible authorities
20 objections have been received from
neighbours living in the proximity of
the premises
the majority of these living in the
college park estate
details of these objections are provided
to
the objections highlight a number of
issues however the only issues that can
be taken into consideration by the
subcommittee
are those that relate to the licensing
objectives
the authority has a duty under section 4
of the licensing act 2003 to carry out
its licensing functions
with the aim of promoting the four
licensing objectives
the objectives are the prevention of
crime and disorder
public safety the prevention of noise
nuisance
the protection of children from the
heart the representations relate to the
licensing objective
of prevention of public nuisance they
raise concerns relating to noise and
disturbance to the neighbouring
residential immunity from noise from the
outside areas
of the big sheep my report highlights
the relevant policy and government
guidance subcommittee will need to
consider when making their decision
now i'm going to refer to the amendment
to the report
the report highlights the key points for
consideration
the noise management plan is detailed
and recommends appropriate measures for
the event organizer to undertake during
an event in terms of points
the noise management noise management
plan
provides a background level of 39
decibels
which has been measured in accordance
with the code of practice and based on
torres district council's own monitoring
and measurements the reported background
level appears to be reasonable
noise management plan does not provide
an actual noise limit
however if the code practice is applied
the event can exceed
background noise by up to 15 decibels
therefore with the 39 background level
events can produce noise up to 54
decibels at the offsite
sector locations identified
the noise measurements undertaken by the
noise consultant and torres district
council's measurements were similar
and appear to indicate that events can
occur without an exceedance
although these events have been operated
in accordance with the coding practice
noise monitoring data and the forms
provided by the objectives
clearly show that the music is still
audible and therefore liable to cause
the noise management plan mentions a
limit on events in future years
citing the common pandemic in support of
businesses as the reason for the number
of events in 2021
this does not specify number moving
forward
the code of practice provides a limit of
12 constant days per calendar year
the noise management plan identifies 23
days of events during
2021. committee will need to weigh the
needs of both parties
the business is looking to recover from
the covered pandemic and to support
other venues by providing events on
their behalf
as they have been unable to operate due
to the coded restrictions in place
however the committee must also consider
the rights of the residents
not to be disturbed by the events taking
place
it may be appropriate in this case to
consider 2021 as an exceptional year
and the committee may be minded to allow
a greater number of events this year
and reduce the number of events going
forward
code of practice states for those venues
where more than three events per
calendar year are expected
the frequency and scheduling of the
events will affect the level of
disturbance
the committee should also consider the
frequency and scheduling of events
the current calendar of events provides
events every weekend in some cases these
events are two or three day duration
throughout the summer
it is important to differentiate between
the different events held on the site
this is identified in the noise
management plan and it is reasonable to
limit restrictions to live amplified
music events
only this will allow unrestricted use by
church groups local schools
theatre performance and the sheep show
is conducted as part of the theme park
nature of the venue
when deciding whether this application
should be granted the subcommittee
should bear in mind that is essentially
making a judgment about risk
is having regard to all the evidence
subcommittee believes there is no
minimal risk of promotion of the license
and changes that the application
should be granted on the terms applied
for if the subcommittee believes that
there are risks which will undermine the
objectives
then it should seek to mitigate those
risks either by modifying the
application
or in case of serious and significant
risk by outright refusal of the
application
under section 35 4 of the act when
determined in its application
the subcommittee must have in regard to
the representations the scene
takes such steps it considers
appropriate to promote the license and
objectives
the options are to grant the application
as
to modify timings and or conditions of
license to the extent necessary to
promote the licensing objectives
committee may wish to consider the list
of possible conditions provided in the
addendum appendix theme
or to reject all or part of the
application
in determining the application the
subcommittee must give appropriate
weight to
the evidence presented at this hearing
guidance issued by the home office under
section 182 of the act
the council's statement of licensing
policy
and any advice given by the council's
vehicle advisor during
any party to the hearing may appeal to
the magistrate's courts against the
decision of the license for subcommittee
this appeal must be made within 21 days
of the date of the modification
of the subcommittee's decision my report
therefore recommends that the
licensing subcommittee determine the
application to vary
the premises license from kicksheet
having regard to the information
provided in this report
guidance issued by the home office on
the section 182 act
council statement of licensing policy
and the evidence presented during the
hearing
thank you chair thank you very much
thank you for that do the panel have any
questions they wish to ask
manager if they wish to make any
comments on the report
yes
it's just a bit strange coming into a
building where there's people actually
whether you don't make these um first of
all
and counselors thank you so much for uh
allowing me to speak
today um i just wanted to give you a
little bit of background about
uh what we've been doing in case you
weren't unaware of it in march
uh 2020 uh we're looking to see how we
continue to operate in the early stages
of cable
uh we looked at whether we could put an
outdoor stage uh to do our shows
uh where we could keep people safe uh
this was purchased in may
and installed in june before we reopened
when it was installed uh simon who runs
the microphone big sheep suggestion we
may be able to
host some live music events and uh as
someone who knows very little about this
um i'm afraid i'm not really a music
buff
but he suggested that we speak to ben
nye who runs the playlist
and also claire who ran the factory in
basketball and also uh richard
um wolfens brown something's wrong
with strange like that sorry
um who runs the uh the plow arts if they
can then
uh give some advice um so using a bit of
north dakota imagination i decided that
we could create spaces in the field that
was safely distance
and we could safely host many people who
were able um who would be happy in this
environment
uh john cox chairman of the biddeford
rugby club volunteered his white line
team to create
circles uh which had to be marked out
with the sticks and straight and a few
cans of sheep spray
um so basically we we created circles in
in the field that we used to use for
sheep trolling and we had a stage in the
front of it
um ben knight from the plane him uses
his contacts to contact some bands and
with the help of toro district council
licensing team
environmental health we hosted the uk's
first live covered safe music event on
the 1st of march
2020 the space was very popular
and won an award for innovation in the
devon tourism awards last autumn
we used the space for our own shows
since some preschool events hosted a
number of local churches to do their
services
and also live music i personally spent
most of my nights we hosted music going
around the town and housing states
speaking to residents
and ensuring that the levels on the
stage were not causing a noise nuisance
and we learned much last summer in
setting levels and understanding the
type
of music which worked in our space i
accept the first few events weren't
great but we learned fast
and i was assured that when the tourist
district council environmental team did
readings they were happy that the levels
were within the
required guidelines we are the only site
of its kind in the uk and whilst other
venues were unable to operate we were
able to come up with a system that
worked for low capacity
great live music supporting the plow
arts with key fundraising and the
palladium to keep ticking over
and promoting for their customers
we covered costs and looked for
opportunities to attract
more live events in 2021
we are in a unique and hugely
challenging pandemic environment
and these music events are a key element
to our plan to try and survive the huge
losses we have sustained because of the
pandemic
running into hundreds of thousands of
pounds we employed a
acoustic consultant to do background
noise level checks during the number of
test events over the past few weeks
and have proved that these can run
within the published guidelines for
music
at all of the nearest residential areas
we hope you'll support this variation to
our existing license
which will allow us to operate music for
over 500 people
supporting our cultural and art sector
the published guidance would allow to 12
events in
a year and we hope that you will treat
this year as an exceptional one
that we can continue with our planned
event supporting plough arts
the palladium and also the local bands
thank you um the panel have any
questions do you wish to ask
mr
my only question is in some respects
is the lateness of the events
2200 hours okay um
[Music]
we've never run to 2200 hours no but
it's
on the it is on the application and and
and for you know for me
i i never intended to go through until
10 o'clock it was uh
it was part of the the published
guidelines that we were able to
start at 10 o'clock and finish at 10
o'clock um
so normally uh we finish between harvest
9 o'clock
um we do we have had a few events over
there
the last few months and it's
particularly tricky in the pandora to
try and get bands on off stage
you everything has to be sterilized all
the microphones have to be changed
all the instruments need to be kept
separate um
and uh so there's one or two of them
that have run over a bit
and also we had a band called e17 it was
such a pain and fun
that uh they refused to go on stage and
they did run over a little bit later but
we've never run an event after 10
o'clock and it was purely that the
guidelines ran up until 10 o'clock
um so you know we try and make sure that
you know we close and we finish before
people
putting the kids to sleep yeah that was
my concern is that
you've got neighbouring estates with
young families and you know
if the families are really young you
know um
then ten o'clock i mean even
even nine o'clock we you know some
people put me kissed about seven or
eight o'clock at night
because they're young enough to go to
school
and i would question you know um
as a parent or a grandparent how i would
feel
if these children didn't get enough
sleep before they went back to
school and sunday
[Music]
is you know i would question
having a live event after
sort of four o'clock on a sunday because
people do need
some peace but you know there's just my
own thoughts no that's that's absolutely
what i would say is that those are my
customers
all of those people with grandchildren
and children are my customers the reason
i spent
hours and hours and hours walking around
i giving out my
personal information my personal mobile
email you know responding to people
and you know if there was uh situations
where
you know last year we decided was too
loud and that's why we've managed to get
to a level
uh that we we no longer have people
following up uh
saying that their children are being
disturbed so you know
in the last certainly none none this
year
uh we had a few at the beginning of last
year when we weren't sure where the
music was traveling
uh but for the last 12 events
at least i've not had a single complaint
of somebody saying
can you turn the music down because my
children can't sleep so um
yeah i mean if if if we lose them as a
customer one of the things about north
dakota we don't have unlimited customers
we've got sea about a mile away and the
fish don't come to visit so that
everyone in north dakota and
particularly in biddeford it's key for
the big sheep to make sure that you know
we try and keep them on our side
okay thank you is there any sort of
further viable sort of practical way
that you can dampen the noise
further you know sort of like without
breaking the bank i know that there are
there is equipment that can be used for
sound better but
i think it's probably cost prohibitive
because like runs into tens of thousands
of pounds
uh we we we have done a lot since we
started uh
and we will continue to do more so that
you know
since last year we built built a new
stage which has a back to it so that
uh the uh any of the speakers that are
heading back towards aperture
you know there's a solid back to it uh
we we have put some
uh they use sort of like big heavy black
wool material
which is good for damping sound we've
got some on there
i'm looking to try and purchase more at
the moment we've increased the size of
the canopy board a whole new canopy that
goes right down to the bottoms which
helps a little bit within
uh the village of ambition we've put
some banks around the the outside of the
field which have helped
uh and also we moved our marquee into an
area where there was a
gap up by the flagpole uh which again
helps to bounce some of the music back
so
certainly you know this year we you know
it has improved substantially
you know and and whatever else that we
can do but it it
it's more about controlling the volume
and also controlling the bands as well
so that's the other thing which we've
learned over the last
uh sort of 12 months is you know we
don't we don't do any sort of heavy
music
you know this is not party central this
is a space where
acoustic music music is appropriate with
somebody with a
you know singer and a guitar um you know
some sometimes it's a bit louder than
others
and you know i've worked with uh you
know
two of the people that are here and
other residents uh to make sure that you
know they give me feedback
you know and and we try and make sure
that it's kept to the level
that is appropriate um and i think we've
been really successful in doing it you
know
so um certainly uh
some lock one a lot of music is not
appropriate for that site and we you
know we accept that and i think that's
uh
another thing which you know we've
learned a lot in the last 12 months
yes um thank you very much
you admit they're being thanks have you
how have you addressed those complaints
i haven't we haven't the
first event that we had you know i had
no idea
i i thought the problem was going to be
an average or i sat in my mother's
farmhouse which is immediately
uh in the village you know and i thought
you know that wasn't a problem
uh and then i you know we finished at
nine o'clock and i put a post on post on
facebook
um and uh um you know we had someone
saying
next time you make sure it's you know
it's please you know it's not
not so ff loud and uh
sorry um but it was um you know so so
that was when you know i spent time
you know walking around you know
speaking to people uh
you know giving out my my personal
details and also
you know i spent a lot of time in
college park londonderry
uh and and also up through um cleveland
road as well
uh depending on the the wind direction
so it is just a
question of reducing the sound so it's
not disturbing and i think
that you know that was also you know as
long as people can
not be disturbed within the house then
that's uh the key element for me
okay um so there is an out of there's
contact number for you
and people have been able to get hold of
you during that advertisement
yeah i've seen some of the letters
objection
that people complained
and the general thread is nothing
appears to have happened
what would your response be to that
that's not right to be honest uh i've
responded to all of them
all of the people behind me have had
correspondence with me as far as i'm i
i'm aware you know
they're aware that we have responded to
them i've i've
personally spoken to them i've been to
the houses for some of these people
um and uh i've done many many miles
walking around just to
you know to make sure that you know
their their complaint is
uh being addressed so you know i've
personally taken
you know responsibility for doing this
uh and i've not been giving it to
another member of the team or another
member of the staff um you know
i i do take this massively personally
you know it is my business you know
and and these are my customers you know
and if i'm upsetting them
it's uh it's going to cost me money
i see on one of the scheduled events
you do have some um what i consider sort
of
heavier rock music um there was like the
beatles and um rolling stones so
i'm thinking that's going to be loud
music um
and that's going up until nine o'clock
on that night
our lady and what would that be it was
just a bit of a pun on the word
so
the music starts at four o'clock uh
there's normally uh
five five different bands that play uh
through the line hopper stein
um and so there's a you know a variety
of
music within the same genre uh for for
each of the events
um i mean all i can say is about the uh
it's like with the bootleg beatles
you know they are the number one
business tribute band
in the uk normally thirty odd thousand
pounds per event
and the fact the fact they've not been
able to play anywhere else for the last
year we've been able to get them for a
reduced price
so uh it is also for me a little bit
about quality as well
you know if you get if you're gonna hear
music playing in the background
if it sounds if someone's trying to kill
the cat then it's probably going to
really really annoy people
i accept that and you know yeah i don't
enjoy
there is about quality one of my
favorites but
i've got to look at a test of
reasonableness as you like
and if somebody is frustrated by hearing
a sort of disembodied sound some way
away
i have to listen to their complaints and
look to see what i
consider would be reasonable even if i
might happen to like that music myself
so how would you respond to that that
yes
this is going to be a live group and yes
they are going on until
nine o'clock i think i think it sort of
goes back to the my personal
responsibility
so that you know if as i'm walking
around
you know if i believe that you know it's
too loud and if the type of music means
it has to be quieter
you know then we can reduce the the
level
um and you know if people are phoning
and
complaining you know they'll have my
personal details
then you know we can look at what we're
doing you know it's it's not a question
well these are the levels we're going to
carry on regardless you know i mean
it it's i suppose it's a it's a personal
commitment from me to make sure that you
know i'm dealing personally with these
complaints
you know i don't i don't want to uh
disturb them
and you know i want to try and do
whatever i can to to try and minimize it
i mean it's uh
um it does require a level of music on
in the in the area in front of the stage
but you know i
i think it you know it can it can be
managed successfully i mean we
we've hold a host many many events
without single complaints
uh and i think you know it it has been a
learning process and it
and it will continue to be a learning
process as well i mean you know with the
bootleg beatles for instance
you know if if afterwards you know they
you know
there is a number of complaints or when
we're listening to it we had to turn it
down and
it it wasn't working you know we then
need to to
you know to re-look at what we're doing
and it you know it has been a continuous
learning process
um and uh we'll hopefully make sure that
it continues to be
you know doing that because i need to
look after the presence of college park
and everybody else
and the musicians were mean able to have
their sounds
reduced at that time rather than so to
say okay
[Music]
he said well the guy that's standing at
the cell death please let the sound
engineer do its job
um you know as my job is to make sure
that the
sound engineer was monitoring and
getting the levels right so it's uh
you know i'm we we will do what we need
to do to make sure that it's appropriate
you know
it is it's my my my business which has
taken a massive pounding
you know we need to try and you know
persuade yourselves and
the residents that you know what we're
doing you know is within the guidelines
is appropriate you know and it's not
going to disturb residents
you know or damage my my brand for me
okay thank you very much thank you
all right are we going to be
because he was meant to be coming today
but obviously when it was moved from
yesterday to today you know he was
unable to uh to attend so i don't i have
it here if they
sure share us in the package that we
okay you've seen it
okay that's fine i don't want to repeat
i don't know it any of the objectives
was to put any questions to
the applicant by yourself oh that's not
actual issue but
um would that be appropriate
it would be yes any questions from you
guys
no um
you don't know me i don't know you
you've never met i don't have your
contact details i don't want to watch
um so you say you know it's
[Music]
you'll get your chance to make
submissions later but could i ask you if
there's a question please
okay so the question is is it correct
that you said to one of the residents
last week that you have repeatedly asked
the
performing act to turn the volume down
and you said
basically there's nothing you can do
about it you're not controlled
on trying to tell them to turn it down
actually not right
i i i i have the authority or the
the it's my side i can pull the flag on
any event at any time
so uh yeah that's not true and we have
shown the volume down
uh like requested residents on a number
of occasions
i mean i'd just like to say that i i
i have been in contact with a number of
people at college park uh
and uh they have a college park facebook
group
uh who um the
uh uh the admin on the on that
uh facebook group invited everybody to
come to a meeting at the big sheet
uh and nobody responded so nobody wants
to actually
come meet up with me on the site so that
was requested a few weeks ago
um so i i have i have tried i've also
put my personal details uh i think
they're on that
facebook site are you a member of the
facebook site
bottom line is that people have
many occasions sorry again chairman can
we ask for questions at this stage as i
said you've got your opportunity to put
forward your case shortly at this stage
it's questions please
the question is
when you're making your submissions that
might be more appropriate
okay thank you i understand about the
noise levels
stage 10 at the bottom of this level and
people
don't need to be as high
um i think the what i would say is
we won't make them louder than they need
to be uh
you know no no but you know this isn't
this isn't like a festival site
you know it's not you know i'm not
interested in people getting blown away
by sound i'm interested in people coming
and listening to music
does it need um be as high for the
environment that you've got there
i think i think it probably depends on
the wind direction and depends on the
bands
so uh yeah it's um you know for some
some bands
definitely not we had uh called
peter jones from manfred band that was
there a few weeks ago you know
it was about 150 people there it was a
very quiet event
you know didn't need to be very loud he
was there playing his harmonica
you know it was very quiet so uh i think
they do vary from one event to another
but
you know all i can say is you know i
don't want them i don't want to be any
louder
um obviously i think everybody
appreciates
the challenges of coding and uh
challenges
in this environment can you manage our
expectations
in future worlds because obviously this
is a request
that becomes a permanent opportunity for
you to
host events make a lot of noise and it
would help us
greatly if you could explain to us in
the longer term what we can expect
in terms of noise pollution from
yourself okay i think
a lot less than we're doing currently so
a because we couldn't afford thirty
thousand pounds to pay for a
van like the bootleg beatles uh there
there
someone like uh frank turner who
performed on stage a few weeks ago uh
he was quoted as a as a music organizer
on
on interviewed on radio 4 uh two weeks
ago so he's you know
top musician in the uk uh that
he appeared on stage on the ninth on our
stage on the 19th of
june uh the last time he was on stage
was the 24th of september
in biddeford at the big sheep so there
was no one else able to
to host events you know nationally uh
for someone
of his caliber we use a you know and
then
you probably don't know his name and and
i don't know most of their names the
only way that i know whether they're any
good is i tend to
go to uh youtube and if they've had like
more than a million hits on youtube then
they're pretty famous and if they've had
more than five million then they're
probably a really good band
uh it's a pretty rough and ready way of
doing it but you know he's had well over
five million hits on
on his his songs um so we will do a lot
less
you know we will do less than twelve i
hope to be able to
have the ability to do up to 12 because
if we if we get an opportunity to
uh maybe have a a top musician that
wants to
warm up for a festival whether it's
blasphemy or lee's festival
you know and he wants to get his band
together and come to north devon you
know i want to have that ability but
going forward i certainly don't want to
be hosting as many uh as we're doing at
the moment it's
you know i'm spending my weekends
walking around college park londonderry
and cleveland road you know it's it's
this is not something that
i really want to do or cherish and it's
not something i'm really enjoying
massively at the moment
um but so we will do
maybe five maybe ten maybe twelve but
you know certainly
we're not looking to hold them nearly as
regularly uh and also the
you know the space is also massively
stressful because most of the people are
sat on grass
and if we get any amount of rain you
know we can't hold an event on a friday
and then hold another one on the
saturday
you know we do have sort of emergency
procedures with
you know if if we had people dancing for
four hours on a on a wet
you know grassy field you know we've got
stone that we can bring in and actually
you know put over the top of the mud but
again you know it's it's
not appropriate on a on a grass field to
do too many events so
i know that the concern was for the lord
of the residents and it came through
in the uh submissions was that the
application
which was you know just a sort of
generic license application
uh said seven days a week ten o'clock in
the morning till ten at night or
whatever it was and then i think it's
it's uh um so there was lots of
confusion and the reason i wanted to
have a meeting with residents was
actually
i don't mind getting criticized for what
we're actually doing but what i do find
really quite tough
is when they're criticizing me for
something that we're not doing so we
will be doing less events
uh next year but i'm not sure exactly
and
and the the reason that we did so many
events this year
was again not through my choice uh was
the fact that the
the plow were basically closed yet
they're not doing anything they had paid
a whole lot of money deposits for these
bands that they weren't able to host
last year
if they didn't host them this year
they'd have lost the money so they used
the bookings that they currently had
you know and some of them are very you
know very small events
um but you know that's why we're trying
to do them
we're doing a a festival uh three-day
festival in september that we've got
programmed and it's basically uh for
grassroots music so there's no you know
they're all people that haven't got any
um
record labels signed um you know for me
you know it's not gonna make any money
doing that event at all
you know so lots of these are not
they're not massively profitable this
isn't something that's going to
make me a lot of money it's something
that i think is really good for north
devon
uh i think given the right type of music
and the number of events it's massively
appropriate
um but yeah we're going to do a lot less
uh christian did you yeah you said you
tried
between eight and nine o'clock uh what
were the finishing times of the last
three events
uh for later that actually yeah uh
i think it was uh about half life just
maybe slightly after
a couple of unfortunately i can tell you
yeah um from inside my house
uh 9 48 i believe it was
12th of june
89 35 was on the 5th
with my window shut that's not a
question
should i be able to hear that
i know i've spoken to your mother on a
number of occasions uh
and uh you know there's certainly so why
in reports you knew about us why weren't
we considered in that report
i think you know we can't uh do
noise readings at every house okay it
was over you put a line in there
that's okay so um
good afternoon everybody could hear me i
can't
get feedback um i'm going to um
read the letter that i sent to mr house
in reply to his email on the 21st of may
2021 and
i apologize if you've already got this
but um because mr hogan and myself have
done some background work
we're going to share the information so
this is based on
uh information on the 22nd of may 2021
dear mr
house i'm writing with concerns about
your email correspondence on the above
subject
dated the 21st of may to 2021
as per other upset residents of college
class i oppose
these new 20-25 events based on the
disturbance intrusion
into our lifestyles last year i was
prepared
to be lenient last year due to all kovid
19
restrictions and compromising the
disturbance knowing that
some people within the big sheep were at
long last able to enjoy themselves
in what could only be described as a
terrible year for everyone
however the noise levels and subsequent
number of regular music events
soon become intolerable but i still
didn't complain and just percy did it
became very obvious
that many local residents felt the same
with social media postings claiming the
music could be clearly heard
up to three miles away in east of the
water so
you can imagine what it was like for
myself
near a mile away particularly in the
height of summer
when the temperatures were high i
couldn't drown the music out in my
modern
new build property with double glazed
windows shut
in fact i couldn't hear the television
above the normal volume settings
or even increasing it five times louder
with all the kovid 19 restrictions there
were far
less people that were allowed to be
within the big sheep
at the events to thousands in the
neighborhoods
having their lifestyles ruined night
after night
therefore i was pleased to think that we
had an opportunity this year
to oppose the license application using
the formal
public registers process on the torres
street council website
uh the state uh is stated that the
applicant mr richard
turner of the big sheep was applying for
a license to include indoor and outdoor
events
i won't go through the full format
because we've all discussed those the
time
but in summary it was um
seven days a week 12 hours a day
with live music or recorded music which
could be
up to three consecutive days over the
weekend
even four if you included a bank holiday
monday
the application was applied for on the
21st of april 2021 the closing date for
representation on the 19th of may
i emailed my representation by email to
the touristy council licensing
on the 26th with a follow-up evidence
from social media posts
on the 27th and had an acknowledgement
from sarah purser of the licensing
assistant
in the meantime i'd contacted mr turner
to discuss matters to see if there was a
way we could find a happy balance to the
issues here at college park
where postings on college park facebook
group were appearing
in discussions i asked rick to email me
details of the intention for the new
things
and let me know the improvements he and
his team have made of big sheet to
suppress the noise
so that i could relay these onto the
residents
that i also suggested that he undertook
voice test events
at set times more importantly before
the live event in the hope that we
provide a happy medium
to suit us all unfortunately nothing
forthcoming happened
so i contacted him again as he welcomed
people in touch
it was suggested that maybe a
face-to-face meeting with polish park
residents
would be a good idea and i agreed to
post on our facebook site
and set up a time and date the response
from the residents was they'd rather go
down the torres street council licensing
formal process
as all the aggravation of last year
ended up in many following
promises that didn't resolve matters now
the courtesy
i relate the information back to mr
turner
a recent meeting with our newly elected
councillor mr jeffrey
wilton love i highlighted this subject
was brewing
and that i'm sure if you hadn't already
been approached by a bit of the western
aviation residents
it wouldn't be long before it would do
so therefore
i hope you can appreciate that residents
like myself before in the correct
procedures and processes
that the council has put in place and
the contacts that i've made
so far we were all under the impression
that torres street council
would uphold their process of holding an
application hearing
and invite us along as per the email
correspondence received back from sarah
person
on receipt of your email of the 21st
already mentioned it looks like you've
done a complete uter
not following the forming process that
you originally set out on the website
in fact i'm sure that you can imagine
this hasn't been welcomed
and your actions need to be questioned
and fully answered before the pig sheet
annoys offense
or otherwise go ahead mr turner
has had more than adequate time to apply
for this application throughout 2021
so far and to leave it so close the
events starting on the 5th of june
it is not a situation to be railroaded
through
by you without taking response forward
is
thus far into account
let me ask you do you think rick mr
turner
is being open and honest about the
variation license to you
the surrounding resident neighborhoods
and playing public
booking events booking these expected
events
to go ahead i personally don't think so
the big sheet as it is being run in the
last six years since i've
relocated here in biddeford does not
cause me any issues
other than those mentions yes previous
firework nights etc may be loud but they
just go on for short periods
what is proposed is a 12 hour period of
over seven days
from early june through september 2021
and then presumably the same year on
you have mentioned the three test events
going ahead on the 5th 12th and 18th of
june
and us to monitor and feedback tourism
council there on
but no the big sheep confirmed events
from the following friday the 25th of
june onwards
that event has already gone ahead so
that one slipped through the net
as per a previous one on the 11th of
june so that is now
five events that you've gone through now
as opposed to
the three that was originally mentioned
this clearly demonstrates to me that you
haven't looked
into this and will have no chance of
reacting to impose cancellation of any
future events
in a time-based way that would suit the
residents
the big sheep are obviously taking this
as a done deal as their website
is active with confirmed dates tickets
bookings camping with no consideration
or warnings for the playing public
that these events may not go ahead here
at college park we are already
inundated with outsiders visiting
development to use the play facilities
at the weekends
there's all already causing us much
distress and we've run this through
our counsellor this is going to be
increased even more if people decide
to do the same as using our
development as a overload car parking
space
can you assure me and residents of
college park
this is not going to happen a new torres
district council
had pre-planned and made resources
available
if you need to tidy up the areas
afterwards such as rubbish disposal
from people returning from the concerts
i urge you to reconsider your decision
or at least defend it especially given
the location of the big sheep
and the distance that the noise travels
on any prevailing wind
up to three miles away as discussed with
mr turner
why doesn't he relocate these events to
an open field stay off the 839
in the middle of nowhere where
disturbance is unlikely to occur
and then only when the council
application license or otherwise
has been approved why approve such
events
where an open stage facing abbotsham
and biddeford community is beyond me
i understand listening to my local
counsellor that similar proposed
nearby events for pig stock last year
were objected to and stopped why
is the same not happening to these
events in relation to the noise
test events i've already mentioned the
three noise test events which were due
to
happen on the 5th 12th and 18th
between the 5th and the 12th there was
another
event that went on which wasn't planned
and subsequently between the noise
events and us being here today
another event occurred last weekend on
friday
to give you some insight because mr
turner says
he's travelled wide around college park
mr hogan and myself
walked college park twice that music was
being played
in some areas yes it was quite adequate
quite in others it was reverberating
off of the college walls itself
or off the care home right in the center
which is a sanctuary
for older elderly people that want the
peace and quiet
and probably as your other councillor
mentioned wants to get asleep
early at night so some of these events
have gone on
way beyond the conflict and information
which is
in the noise report which says all then
stop at nine o'clock
and we've had events going on to 21.45
which has been
already reported and 2130
has already reported so we we got
conflict of information
on the noise um information that says
we'll then
stop at nine the application sounds
going on to ten
and mr turner is telling us it's not
going anywhere near that time
but we can assure you it's going on and
the intrusion into our lives
is intolerable at the moment
we understand that um the big sheep is
recorded as being
north devon's number one attraction i
can assure you
this is our number one distraction
thank you
we'll be taking questions individually
or
chairman you can put the questions to
the objective first of all
it just says it's like um on the thing
about asking objectives
uh you know at the end of this obviously
what i might suggest german is it may be
useful for the licensing officer to
comment on some of the things that were
raised
yeah as detailed in the report
[Music]
we were we decided to hold the free test
events
in order to gain noise monitoring
um hence why we allowed the free test
events
whereas mentioned two other events there
is an exemption
under the live music act 2012 which was
subsequently amended
by the legislation reform entertainment
licensing order 2014
which allows premises with
a on sales alcohol license
to hold live music events
without the requirement for a license
providing there is less than 500 people
so under the live music exemption you
can hold the
events without the need for a license so
those events we can stop those events
there's no reason to stop those events
um the three bigger events were the ones
we decided to use
as the trial events in order to gain the
information
in the report we felt it was in the
public interest to
have those free test events so we could
get the detailed
um information else we'd have to come to
this committee without
any detailed information and you
have to make a decision based on based
on you know
objectives and yeah
i think the difficulty with your test
events at the moment
is they're totally subjected to the
weather conditions
the first one on the fifth in the
evening the weather conditions were a
nine mile now south westerly wind which
is in the direction towards cottage farm
but it was drizzling so it dampened a
lot of the noise
if you get a similar prevailing wind
and it's a dry condition sunny evening
that noise just
travels as we said three miles to east
water
and in some cases when we walked around
college park development on
uh friday it was bouncing off of large
buildings and reverberating back
and it's not always the case that the
closest part
of college park to the big sheep
is the noises because the noise is
traveling over
and above whereas all the noise readings
have been taken with equipment
at waist height
i know we saw you playing monitoring
visits on that particular occasion
um although although the noise was
audible
you agree that it's an acceptable level
um
15 minutes past five when i first met
you
it was almost like it had been purposely
turned down
it was that quiet because prior to that
when it started
at 15 40 it was as loud as you
recorded later on the evening
between 7 and 8 30
and then again at 9 00 and 9 30.
the noise levels that you experienced
was nothing to what we had last year
but as we you know as we suggested that
those were test events so we've
obviously done some monitoring
in that location as well as other
locations
and as per the noise management plan
that would be
that would be a crucial part of the
monitoring that obviously
weather conditions will when the
conditions on the day of events will
come into play so
if the wind's in a certain direction
there might be a focus by a particular
location
during that event and if levels are
above um what's being stipulated
then they'll be they'll be measured in
place presumably and hopefully
we'll be able to control that
if the weather affects it that seriously
then the venue is a completely wrong
location
the venue is within aberchan village
and very close to college park and very
soon there's going to be another
development between college park
and big sheep so if you don't
adhere to the problems now and
cancel them then this would just run and
run and run
but in terms of the actual noise levels
um
through consultants monitoring and
throughout it's been demonstrated that
it would comply with the code of access
well you've had some situations they're
53.9 db's and the limit is 54.
it's only just under in some cases some
of the noise readings which is
the other side the a39 where you've got
cards
suppressing the noise in there you can
still hear it above that
the other side the a39 so you're not
understanding
that the noise levels 54 db may not
be as loud as what your specification is
that it's intrusion into people's lives
and
i don't i don't dispute that and you
know personal noise monitoring was to
say demonstrate that there would be what
could be compliance with
with the code of practice but that's
yeah the fact that
you can still hear them so i'm not just
youtube but would you like to live where
i am
when the height of summer when we can
get up to near 30 degrees
i'd like better windows open than
evening and i can't have the windows
open
because this music that i don't want to
hear is drowning everything
out in my house it's unacceptable i'm
sorry
your guidance your noise limiter of
guidance is all the other factors you
must take into account
we're not making a decision whether we
hit 54 decibels
or above we're making a decision on the
intrusion
and upset into people's lives and
businesses here
sure if i'm there um i would like to
compare with mr conwell here that
15 decibels of a background is audible
um and you know it will be audible um
through windows and within properties as
well
the code of practice seems seeks to
strike a balance
between um uh businesses and
you know legitimately trying to to make
um a living
and but also the reasonable expectations
of the of the residents as well so
yeah this is a difficult decision for
for from members as chris mentioned in
his in his
uh introduction um it's
we have to determine a balance uh
between the two it's down to numbers to
to determine if it's gone too far what
one way or
or another but we're not saying that the
uh the event can
and should be uh carried out and to
another
an inaudibility standard and uh external
events by their very nature
and will be uh audible to um
uh um residents around and about
and um wind and weather will have
an impact on that and three test events
seem
reasonable to gather data and
information
in order to be sure of our case and
present that to
its members thank you
okay thank you give me the opportunity
um basically you every day you will all
have
your own issues things that's wound you
up
somebody's annoyed you at work on the
way home someone's cut you up in
road rage you've gone to a shop to try
to get something you've queued up for
ages
and they haven't got it you're wound up
when you get home
you put the key in the door you go in
you close that door and you put the
kettle on and you want to sit down
in the sanctuary of your own home peace
and quiet
shut that world out okay everybody has
got the right to enjoy their property
and to have
silence in their own house okay when you
come home and you shut the door
and all you can hear is music be it
music that you do like
or music you don't like it's an
intrusion
that basically like a chinese water
torture tap
dripping away drives you insane okay
and that's what's happening to many many
people in orange park
and it isn't unacceptable now i've got
another issue going on which i won't go
into here but it's again to do with
noise and it isn't the fact of the
volume in my opinion the volume of the
noise
it's the actual the um
presence of it there's a constant
reminder there's something there
so for example you've got somebody like
in your next-door neighbor
my brother had years ago the guy used to
12 hours a day
would be in his garage with a grinder
grinding metal
never found out what the hell he was
doing but the noise wasn't
a level that the council would class as
illegal or breaking limits but it was
still an intrusion
you could still hear it inside the house
of the window shut
now the position where i live i can hear
the music
and i can hear the music in my house
with the window shut
now to me it doesn't cause that much of
an issue but i can hear it
when the tv is turned off or when
there's a quiet section in the tv
if i have the windows open or the patio
doors open
which is facing the big sheep i can
clear it and clearly hear it
what i don't like is having my
six-year-old and four-year-old grandson
in my garden and hearing artists using
the f word
resonating over my property okay
that to me is unacceptable i'd also like
to question
who decided where these particular sound
monitoring
locations would be taken because as
peter said on the event of the 12th of
june i could clearly hear the event
in my back garden and in my house but it
wasn't at a level that was really
bothering me but i could still hear it
there's a lady vanessa elaine who on i
believe i'm speaking on behalf of
alderman she said she wanted to speak
for or not she said she would
vanessa lane she lives on needs drive
she has a insomnia problem she has
terrible sleep patterns
and she has been driven to insanity by
the music going on so late
and as others have already said it's not
finishing at nine o'clock
it's going past i mean the last three
ones they've all gone past that time
okay now from where my property is
on the opposite side of the estate it's
slightly elevated to
mr lanes and she's her property is down
near to where the cottage park backs
onto wall park road
and beautiful college now when i went
for a walk around
this level of noise on her part of the
estate
was substantially increased to where i
was
and you could clearly hear the drums and
the guitars
and the vocals bouncing off of the
college park building
the college get different college
building and
some of the residential properties on
morton park road
that was bouncing into college park
estate
i pointed it out onto the facebook group
to say
are you aware that the sound is
different in different locations
and people started doing their own
little surveys and yes they could find
that there was places on the estate
where you could barely hear it and other
places it was
really really bad so on
friday when keith and i did the walk
about and i was explaining to keith
how this was again we identified various
locations
in college park where the audio was
the noise was substantially louder than
other places
even to the point where you could walk
maybe 10 feet
and you would hear it okay i hadn't
noticed until i went to that walk with
keith
that when you walk around birdwood
presents and you get to the junction of
blackmoore avenue
the side of mountain court residential
home which has got these elderly people
with their doors that they want to have
open in summer and the music
was just bouncing off it and going back
up like
now when we took that walk around they
were playing lovely
irish dvd league music my old
backgrounds irish that doesn't bother me
i quite like it
other people wouldn't like it and i
certainly wouldn't like it if it was
the beatles playing or whatever other
groups
you've said it's to me
uh totally unacceptable as to why
yes we've got a plan we've had a
pandemic loads and loads of businesses
struggling
they're all in the same boat but how can
one business be allowed to ride
roughshod
over a whole community and other web
established local businesses
that if this level of activity goes on
it will have a continuous impact on our
lives
our mental health well-being and
it will probably put other businesses
out of business
it just doesn't seem to make sense to me
now
mr turner has said that he's he's done
regular walk-abouts
and as i said to him i've never met him
i had to
keep out to tell me who he was when we
first walked in i said he was to turn it
because i've never met him
okay i had uh before we moved down here
and when we didn't move down here
regularly went to the big sheep as the
farming activity with my grandchildren
we purchased a um an annual ticket
for our grandchildren to go to big sugar
so i've supported the big sheep
i've supported a local business and i
try to support other local businesses
what i don't support is when you've got
one business
that wants to just take it all and
ride rushford over everybody for one
so they can make their business work and
be down to everybody else
to me it's just not on
this um the resident that said to me
that mr turner i mean somebody's i say
someone's telling the truth
someone's lying the resident who spoke
to me on the night it happened
he said that um rick had spoken to him
and said that he asked him to turn the
music down he didn't they'd also pointed
out the fact that while he was cleaning
his car
in the evening in the early evening he
could hear the big sheet music over his
vacuum cleaner
and then he was bleeding the car right
that's how loud it is
there's the issue of um parking
now last year there was parking events
when i was seeing the parking on average
road
when it was pigstock where basically
they've got
double parking all the way down
aberration road they had marshalls
outside
chairman i'm wondering can we keep the
representations with regards to
the events that are taking place in the
noise and
these are the elements that we're
looking at today and the licensing
objectives
as to whether or not there's a
prevention of public nuisance and that's
what we're
looking at i think i mean yeah okay
so i don't want to cut you off when i
have to say i'm just mindful that we
need to be relevant when we're making
representations so what
what part of all these things well i'd
say
your comments with regards to the noise
elements relevant not
the more do you respect if you've been
to the big shoot before when you first
opened
uh so as i say i apologize
yeah okay um so let's get on today
double parking on ambition road litter
bolts being thrown over people's gardens
by drunks working their way home
um the road being so narrow that
basically when cars are trying to go
down ambition road
people are walking in the road what
about if there's ambulances or fire
emergency vehicles trying to get through
there they can't get through
because it's complete mayhem we're
called overflow parking people parking
outside my house
and coming back late at night drunk with
their friends with their
um nominated driver but i don't care how
much noise they make outside the house
uh
i think that'll cover what i need to say
really
[Music]
i'm going to test the evidence
how many complaints have we received
from
residents in this area
from when this this year we've had the
20 we have the 20 objectives and then in
the addendum for the report it's the
noise monitoring undertaken at the test
event
plenty objective and we would estimate
the population
of these two estates at what sort of
figure
unfortunately the biggest
[Music]
sin of mankind is apathy where basically
people just don't bother complaining
so as nick um
rick is to turn around mentioned about
the facebook groups on our estate
yes the previous facebook group was
didn't post that question and and keeps
giving the answers for it
the group has now changed hands because
the original person's now
his movement is leaving to start refresh
but
the volume of people that were airing
their views
on the facebook group is nothing
compared
is uh what's the word is greatly
more than those that have actually made
official complaints
now likewise for this other problem that
i'm having a lot of people
are frightened to make complaints
because when the time comes to the point
of selling their house
searches are made as soon as they've
made any complaints
if they've got any issues the point in
case the house two doors up from us
has actually just moved and they moved
and they moved for a particular reasons
happening in our estate
and they kept completely quite about it
and they said we're sorry we can't do
anything to help you
it will affect our sale because that's
the box happens
in society
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is there somebody who can speak to the
evidence put forward by that military
you would have to do that john okay
thank you
thank you um i live in port college park
um i did have um some contact with rick
turner last year
by complaining um and he did say that he
would address the problems of the same
same to me hasn't hasn't appeared this
year it's still
exactly the same as what it was last
year um
i didn't measure the same on friday
night in my own garden
and i live at the top end of college
park so there's only
one set of paces between me and then the
sea open fields
to the big sheep and that's coming up at
52
and up at 54.
my only because my only problem is that
i can say that garden and my family
and enjoy the outside and particularly
at the front moment when we got covered
they're asking you to have your windows
open and your doors open and save
with the present statement playing when
it is when it is there
you have to shut your doors shut your
windows turn the tv up
and you land them in the closed space
and i just don't think that's acceptable
that's that's my main thing i think a
lot of the other things have been
addressed by
keith and
i think you've been aware of repetition
that's that's great thank you
oh anybody love to ask any questions
we've heard that the events have
overrun in the past
in your experience does the music and
the noise
taper off or does it crescendo towards
the end here
it's exactly the same i mean i picked my
son up
on on this saturday the previous
saturday from asda up on the valley road
and he finished it past nine and it
sounded like they said the actual
concert was actually in the car park of
the premier room it was that late and by
the time i got home
uh chris um am i right in thinking that
um ten o'clock is the cut-off point and
i've am already thinking that um events
have been
the aim has been to finish at 9 30. but
there's
that cutting off period so that there
could be an encore or whatever but at
the actual
limits of the license is 10 the general
acceptable level or acceptable period so
music's up to 2300 and 11 o'clock
that this license has been submitted
with a 10 o'clock closure
with the idea of running up until nine
half past nine and then the site's
all cleared and everything's completely
by ten
okay that's the um but basically we have
a license application
the application can put in any time
generally up to
eleven o'clock it's more acceptable to
go into later
after 2300 that's when more stringent
conditions
come into play
thank you
question should i bring my mother as
well because i'm representing the
business
that you can she could represent
hi um so you've heard from the
objectives
who live at least one mile away
in college park and now you're hearing
from a business which is
0.2 miles away in the direction of the
stage
all of the testing which has been done
it's it's been done in locations which
don't really reflect
us and we can tell you it is completely
unacceptable it is way too loud
on top of that we are trying to run a
business which is a better breakfast we
are from uh low winds with bmv
um we we have a lot of guests who come
there for quietness
for taking a break to get away from the
noises from the city from everything
and to come on a friday night which a
lot of our guests do
leave on a monday and to come you know
this friday
we had guests arrive and three minutes
later they said well is the music
running all night
is it every night and we had to
apologize we had to tell them
yes tonight it's on and possibly
tomorrow we're not sure
um we just want kind of to put our point
forward that this is really going to
affect
us and you can see i've given you a
little tip with some additional stuff in
uh you can see our location uh it is
within the front opening of the stage
direction we are
extremely close um you can see what we
have as feedback from our guests which
say it is a really extremely quiet
location to stay
the front of the house is basically
facing towards the stage the upper
bedrooms that we let
you can hear it inside with the windows
shut um
it's it's not fair on us uh
it will affect us it's not a matter of
if it's a matter of when
uh that's what we're really worried
about in the report
it did say uh low into the court lies at
360 meters
we aren't lower winds lower winds we're
slightly closer but benefits from higher
ground road noise and benefits from
natural
topographical screening uh which i kind
of review if you look at it further in
the pack
you can kind of see that there's a seven
meter
slope going from the big ship up to a
house
uh big sheep lying at 42 meters our
house line is 49 meters
and it's just a gradual slope there is
no dip
uh we aren't screamed by anything we're
in full frontal
of the speakers the winston court
correctly
is screamed by our house they lie about
seven meters below our house
so they they will not experience the
same noise as us but we did speak to our
neighbor
who hasn't complained because he's only
just moved in
and asked him what he thought of the
noise and he said i thought it was
coming from your house
he honestly thought that the music was
coming from our house
i have stayed in quieter festival
sleeping sites
and then this it's it's literally like
it is next door
um if you look at where college park is
lying
um they are quite well protected
by the hills so i just ask you to try
and imagine
being five times closer being only seven
meters
uh elevation higher with no screening to
just imagine what we experienced and
also the added stress it puts
us through having to worry about our
guests every time someone arrives
every time someone needs the feedback
they might give us and how that might
hurt our business i understand that
rick's business
did get impacted by the granovirus and
we did too
we weren't fortunate enough to be able
to think of
a solution like holding outdoor events
to gain back
some of our business we just had the
role of the countries unfortunately
and that's where we are today we are
23 events which can affect us that's
what we're
what we're trying to put forward here um
i don't think there's much
more to say which isn't echoed by
everybody else
so welcome questions
questions
um i can see by
by what you sent this um that your
clientele enjoy a very
peaceful and quiet location
this is obviously affecting your your
business
would um a compromise
having uh limited events
as opposed to doubling the amount i'm
thinking of years to come as well would
that still be something that you would
oppose
well um i welcome the sound report and i
welcome the guidelines which is set in
place the 15 decibels above the ambient
background sound we welcome that
but we welcome that testing done at our
location
five times closer to the uh the stage
is that possible that that could be
arranged
yeah absolutely um if
the committee are minded to put such a
noise limit and it would be applicable
to basically anywhere where we get
complaints we're
invited to uh to monitor
and what we tend to do in terms of um
agreeing noise monitoring locations
we're looking for
suitable locations which can be um
easily and readily accessed throughout
an event
and we're looking for worst case
scenario uh
locations as well so we wouldn't measure
everywhere we will try to measure
at the closest properties to the event
and depending on on wind direction and i
am unsure why low winds wasn't picked up
um as as part of that and and
but that that certainly something that
could be influenced as a safe members
who might have to put that noise
and the residential premises i
appreciate it's a business but i'm
assuming that you also
live there as well uh yes yes yes so it
would be classed as a residential
apprentices
okay yeah um can i add though
uh maybe because we can't really give a
as you said the 15 decibels above the
background sound is too much for my
fellow objectives
already and we can't yet get to that
position to complain
because we just don't know what it is in
our area
it could be possible that it is
unacceptable for us at that level
in our area and then i would say that we
would completely object
to the licensing at the moment i can't i
can't say that i want to be fair
that's better thank you chairman if i
can just interject i'm going to
show you a web that's one of the
possible conditions
on the back page of the supplementary
reports so
all the various
only the only thing um would i would say
for that location
is that we may have to look at um the
background level as well
because that is closer to the road there
so the the background level so we've
talked about
um 54
it may be different at that at that
location
could be 46 which would make it
yeah um
um i see various options here
but can we put a time
stipulation when the events must
cease
i haven't put it in the possible
conditions because it's not actually
conditionally an allocation of the
timings but if i refer you back to the
report
and your decisions and conclusions in
6.2 is
to modify timings and or conditions of
license so the example were obviously
conditions of license
there's nothing to stop you remembering
the timings that have been applied for
and to be clear the test events
were due to finish at ten o'clock not
nine o'clock
the yeah the license applied for was
through ten o'clock so we wouldn't put
those conditions
yeah right so in fact they were
finishing early and stipulated
i think i think where the confusions
come i think the advertised
finish times for possibly 9 30
but in accordance with the license
conditions if you
condition these events to finish at 10
then they can go
up until 10 and a half
but as i said generally we
would give a little leeway because as as
it's been already mentioned that is
have the tendency to want to do it or go
on with it
so the idea behind having a 9 30 finish
would then give you that half hour
leeway to
do we have any knowledge of any
other external events of this nature
which are in that sort of environment
such as this
american trust for something we've got
the pig stock event but that's only a
once a year event
we've also got another couple of
festivals that are more rural
and again restricted to a weekend event
we haven't got
any events licensed in our
area they've got the frequency of these
elements
and in the proximity of that
resolution how about
looking beyond our area have we done any
research
the standard that we're talking about
the practice on um
environmental noise control is used
across the country
so that's the uh the the standard by
which
um avenues or licensing um
assessments are carried out so i have
i've i've used that
standard at other local authorities it
isn't
is that a similar sort of distance away
from presidents
get this slightly different
democrat and again we have we've never
had any complaints so we
got conditions in place but we haven't
gone as far as
learning corporate practice but there
isn't specific conditions as we haven't
had any
complaints and the license was applied
for without objection
obviously if we didn't receive
complaints it would then come to an
evening
as is this case but in the absence of
complaints
um really not stipulating there's a lot
of this down to the fact that some of
these other events
are one-off events throughout the year
so
residents or people are looking forward
to it
where if there's a lot of events in one
area
constantly happening is that
is that a cause for concern for the
residents because
there is no respite from
what's going on i mean you know playing
devil's advocate if you like
um you know you wouldn't want
seven days a week or every weekend
you know any human being would like
respite to be able to sit in their
garden with their feet up
and listen to the birds and not listen
to
whatever is going on all through the
summer
because it's just i mean personally i
would find it intolerable i think
but um you know
limiting how many events may be a
a much better use
of what's going on because otherwise
you're going to have an impasse here
you know people are going to be
bombarded with
concept it's not only the big shoot
having their events but then
obviously you've got school fates going
on and all sorts of other noise
looting things and um
you know it's just a thought that
perhaps trying to
limit the events so i mean i appreciate
there's a financial consideration here
but that's not i don't think that's our
reasoning
[Music]
because you've got one business that's
going to make
money and then you might have another
business
because their their business model
is based on tranquility and peace
i've got to lose money and that's
so that's you know if you look at it
from a business point of view
you've got you've got a business that's
going to make money
and reap the reward of
what they're doing and you're going to
have perhaps i don't know how many
businesses
um so i don't
um you know
how many other bmbs or or other
businesses
within about the location
um have
had you know would lose money because
it's not
quiet and peaceful it's noisy
considerations
that you know one business wins
how many businesses locally i think
janet whatever that's a few uh
just to to uh clarify in terms of the uh
the current practices that we're using
the general projects that the less
events that you have
the more noise allowance you have so for
the the one-offs or the annual events
you know even if it's a couple of days
they're allowed a far greater um
level of noise because you don't have
that unions of effect and when you have
more events
the illness is on the operator to to be
quieter
yes yeah and that's that's the general
report
each day is um a noise event
so according to me that we could have
practiced up to three
um events or or three days and there
will be
far more allowance given um
oh
it's still as loud as what
um has been measured for these events so
far so
yeah so that's right you know over three
days and even
you know three-day festival and it's
that's that's part of the balance that
we've talked about um
so what we'll talk about in relation to
mr turner's three-day event later on
that will be part of the overwatch
i believe that we would suffer greatly
if there was a three-day festival
uh in that proximity yeah the three-day
festival that is planned for september
would have to come within the
bands of this license anyway so it
wouldn't be you know
separate it wouldn't be a 65 despo event
it would be you know
the same thing but that's sort
[Music]
night management plan given for the
number of events going forward
forward mentioned earlier that there was
going to be 12.
well i'll call this practice all to
suggest to say german is that that is
something that you could add as a
condition
you can add a condition which is on the
back page at the moment for this year
and how many essentially yes
indeed and there you can add a number
for future events you may also find it
uh worthwhile to limit the number of
events that may occur
over a weekend and again there's a
suggested condition
on the back what i would suggest to
chairman is that if
you potentially may be minded to do that
you might want to come back in
and to canvass the opinion of the
parties
before you make the final decision
because the guidance does say
to to hear from the parties and obtain
their comments upon
the proposals before making a final
decision
thank you yeah are we able to recall
any of the witnesses we previously heard
in this junction
to what end i have further questions
at the end of this process so that he
can sum up so
obviously
[Music]
i own moreton house and morton house
devon limited
business we have at northern house thank
you very much for
taking the time to listen to me so i'm
going to talk about this issue
from the fact from the impact on my
family and then
i'll cover the issues with my business
so uh as a family i have two young
children
and a wife we live at horton house which
is
a few if you look at the way that rick
has built his stage
where he funnels the music away from
abbot sherman
directly towards west biddeford
you get lower winsford then mr stevens
farm
than us and then you're into the new
developments
uh so um
we experience uh mr turner's music
inside the house and uh
i'm not aware of any monitoring of the
noise
at moreton house but being a big old
georgian house with big flat surfaces
get a lot of reflection of the sound so
it's
very audible in and around uh modern
house
inside horton house but we're also
very aware of all of the stress and
problems that
businesses like the big sheep have had
with kovid
totally sympathize with what he had to
do last year in order to have any kind
of
activity at all and sympathize and say
entirely with
his objectives of trying to help uh
other businesses
survive like a plow um
nevertheless uh it has been
uh quite an experience uh having that
volume of noise
on the family and it certainly has
distressed
my wife extremely at the thought that
this might
persist for years to come which is the
nature of the license it's been applied
for
talking about it from business
perspective we're quite conflicted
because
we have a holiday let business which is
now up and running
and our holiday let customers don't
write to the council to complain they
complain to us
when the noise is severe and obviously
we have a lot of sympathy with mr turns
we don't bring him every time one of our
customers complains
um so we we try and allay their concerns
on the spot
but uh clearly going ahead into the
future
our customers are paying a premium to
stay in what we think is a very lovely
location and having
the uh high volume of noise
is definitely having an impact on the
ambience of
our property from their perspective
but we also have another business we're
going to be doing events we're going to
be doing
indoor weddings and and that sort of
thing so it's given us a lot of conflict
in terms of
this issue has raised lots of noise
related issues with our immediate
neighbors
and they've given us lots of reason to
concern of the concern
i think it's been quite interesting
listening today and learning all about
how you look on all of that
um clearly if mr turner is granted this
license and is able to do this volume
of noise until 10 o'clock every night of
the week
we won't be doing any weddings in the
garden that's clear
but uh you know we will still be able to
do stuff inside i guess
once you've got a few people talking and
probably cover out the noise
but from our point of view uh i can only
say that when we saw how he built his
stage
where it projects all the noise straight
at us it was a complete
we didn't understand what we've done to
annoy them such that they would pick
to do that to us and um it's been quite
distressing
thank you very much thank you any
questions
uh
thank you uh obviously i have huge
amounts of sympathy for people that are
being disturbed
we we uh have people
that come from all over the country to
listen to these live events
i know lots of them go and stay in the
bmv at uh
low windsford i know lots of them will
be staying
in uh morton house uh you know i've
spoken to harvey's wife
a few weeks ago i gave him my personal
mobile number
and said you know if the levels were uh
at the nuisance level if she could
please contact me it's never been done
so uh i i you know i do get that uh
in in historically when we first started
doing them the noise levels were were
quite loud people were asked to complain
uh they were asked on the facebook group
to complain uh
but and we've got four people five
people here today
you know that are not very happy there
is loads and loads of other businesses
that we're helping and supporting
whether it's
uh musicians whether it's food operators
whether it's
uh accommodation providers that are
benefiting from from what we're doing
and i just like to try and give a bit of
a balance to
some of the uh things you've just heard
in the last hour
um so uh when
we were doing the uh the sound readings
uh the
engineering went into one of the closest
houses
in londonderry and put his uh equipment
and the lady came to the house and said
are you doing some
uh noise readings and he said uh yeah i
i am
she and she said well is there anything
to do with the
concerts and the bands that are playing
with the big sheep and he said well
actually it is
and she said well i absolutely love them
she said i love the music
you know cheers me out and i know lots
of the neighbors do
last weekend i i was walking through
college park there was two people sat
outside having a glass of prosecco in
their garden
in the house that's closest to the the
venue and
uh and i said i'm just coming around
like to find out
you know what you think about the noise
levels and uh you know
are they disturbing you and then the
couple said um
will you turn up the music because we
love it we like to avail to hear it
um so there are there is a
you know there is a balance um i i asked
uh if we could put on the the college
park facebook group which has
used to have about 217 members um
if they could uh find out you know what
people's views were
uh this is before i go on to do to have
a meeting with them all
uh and and it came back from the the the
um
uh ray who ray richards who was the uh
the admin
uh he said three people are dead against
it a double a dozen not all for it
the rest haven't commented so i assume
they don't mind either way
so there there is a balance you know
obviously uh
it's like if you go into a room and you
can hear a ticking clock i mean it's
amazing that some people can't sleep in
a room because the clock's ticking
you know most people don't even hear the
clock they don't even know that it's
going on
and i know that some people do become
sensitized and if you you know if you're
already wound up and you start to hear
something that
upsets you you know it tends to upset
you more
so you know i do think there is a
balance you know this is an exceptional
year with
you know we are doing something unique
so this doesn't
there isn't precedence for doing what we
do no one else has done this in the
whole of the uk you know this this isn't
happening anywhere but north seven
um and uh you know we've worked really
really hard to try and make sure that we
make it appropriate for music we make
the levels appropriate when the sound
engineer
came to the site the acoustic specialist
that we were asked to employ
uh so it cost i think two and a half
thousand pounds for this
this consultant to come in and do all
this all this testing
and uh and we said you know at the sound
desk which is 30 meters away from the
front desk
uh we try and operate at uh under
uh you know whatever the level was and
then we gave them a level the challenge
and he was operating on he said
rick i can't believe you operated that
low you know i've never come across
and this is someone who does it for a
living this is what he does testing
music levels venues all over the country
he said
i've never come across anywhere that's
operating with this level and the reason
we operate at that level is because i've
been spending
my time walking around college park
walking
around londonderry speaking to uh i
think
harvey's wife makes claire you know to
make sure that you know i've been to the
house
you know they wouldn't come out and
speak to me but i've been to the house
um you know i it upsets me that uh
although i've i've i've um spoken to two
of these people on on facebook you know
they they've never wanted to meet me
i've met loads of others that have
you know so we've reduced the levels to
make sure that it's appropriate
so you know we have thought it through
and it is difficult because
you've obviously heard four people that
are complaining there are thousands of
people that have loved what we've done
you know it is totally magical
um to watch people we've been going
through absolute [ __ ] with cobras
you know the mental health of most of
north devon and the rest of the country
is absolutely in the ditch you know no
one's been
able to listen to live music to get out
and enjoy it um and you know we have
provided something which
which we think is pretty pretty unique
um and
we are in this in a difficult situation
at the moment we're trying to do more
than we would ever do
you know and some of the
misunderstandings that are going on with
the complainers or about
the number of events we're doing we're
never going to do that we're not going
to be operating every day
you know as one of the the band said the
other day said brit you couldn't afford
it
you know i i might be able to afford
eight or ten
or maybe 12 a year but i certainly
couldn't afford more than that you know
we don't have a site that's going to
make me a lot of money out of this
you know we one event last year cost me
three and a half thousand pounds we lost
three and a half thousand pounds with
this event so
this isn't something that's massively
profitable operating a socially
distanced music event and the reason no
one else has ever done it
in that in the rest of the country is
they can't afford it you know
we are marginal um we have 25 volunteers
from the palladium
that give up their time they run the
reception they do the security
uh they make sure they show people to
the circles they clear up afterwards
you know it's it's bitter for volunteers
that are there helping to make it happen
the plow has its own volunteers they
don't pay any of them all these
volunteers
turn up because they wanted to try and
happen um so
i i i know it's you know it is difficult
you know it's an emotive
it is an emotive subject you know and uh
you know we think we're operating at an
appropriate level we're operating within
published guidelines
um going forward you know and i will
personally
you know assure you that i'll do
whatever i can uh
to make sure that i've i've spoken to
sandy numerous times you know her and
the guests have been down
you know to the events last year um and
uh you know i will communicate with them
i'm not gonna
you know i take it personally i mean
rightly or wrongly
you know i i've done it for 30 years and
i
i personally take responsibility for
everything that we do on the site
sorry i'm just uh thanks for that
right um i'm i'm sure you're itching to
ask a question
you make your case very passionately and
eloquently
you've heard the objectives here
and i think we as committee would want
to
balance your your business
interests some of the other business
interests and the reasonability
of the fair enjoyment of the immunity of
residents
of a particular area um
of the things that we can look at is the
timing of events
what would be the
earliest time when you feel you would
finish an event
in the evening and hold to that time
you know if you put nine o'clock and
i saw that testament come forward with
later punching parking out record stuff
after that
advertised time yes i understand
from our officers why that is um
what could be the earliest reasonable
cut-off time that you could say your
event
could close what you
could satisfy the interests of the band
and your customers
i mean nobody nobody finishes a music
event at ten o'clock
no one finishes at nine o'clock i hope
it was nine i mean when i spoke to the
licensing officer
uh mr park house you know he he said you
know normally
you know the license will go to 11
o'clock i said look you know i want to
finish it at nine o'clock the hog was
nine
and he said okay let's put ten o'clock
so we make sure that you know you've
finished
and and you know we do have you know
things that happen
you know sometimes the music goes down
someone you know
turns up late someone you know uh with
one of one of the changeovers it doesn't
run smoothly you know what we've got a
band plank you know and everyone's
absolutely
rocking and apart from pulling the plug
out you know when they're all wanting a
a uh an envelope
you know and so so you know i you know
we haven't
gone beyond 10 o'clock you know we've
never done beyond 10 o'clock and i
apologize we'll be going as late as we
are because my
my whole thing is you know we should be
uh running until people start to put the
kids to bed
so you know nine nine o'clock is you
know is my thing that i should i think
we should be winding it down
you know sometimes if it runs over until
quarter past nine hoppers nine that's
fine you know when it's at ten to ten
that's you know chipotle's a bit late
but
you know the the you know you know it is
still really early i mean for a music
event i mean most
most people you know don't even go out
to a music event until nine o'clock
you know and and most of the other ones
around the country you know the reason
that the
the um acoustics people get involved is
that they're running at two o'clock in
the morning
you know they're you know they've got me
live music going on 20
you know pretty well throughout the
whole night you know which is obviously
massively disturbing but you know all
i'm trying to do is to make sure that
you know i minimize people that we upset
because they're my customers you know i
mean i've i've already lost one season
ticket holder behind me
you know and i don't want to lose any
more i can't afford to lose anymore
you know we just don't have enough
customers for me to upset people
so you know we do think that it's
appropriate what we're doing and i spent
a long time
uh you know with licensing you know uh
to to try and make sure that the
application that we put through was
you know was appropriate and and was
doable as well um so i think you know we
are
you know we're closing pretty early it's
like you know people sort of say why
you know can't believe you're finishing
it uh office line i said well we've got
residents you know that's that's what
we're going to do if you want to come in
you know this is when we're going to do
the music
and the other suggestion put by
some of um the witnesses was the stage
is
facing the wrong way from their point of
view
it's funny towards their businesses is
there a possibility that the stage
could be recited we have cited it and
we've changed the
the the sighting from last year to this
year
to make sure that we uh try and minimize
the impact you know we've
we've moved 20 uh 20 000 tons of
stone uh into the field and a big bank
around the back we've moved the
you know the marquee purely so that it's
between us and college park
and and you know the houses behind so
you know we have done a lot
you know if if there are other things
that we can do you know this is you know
this is an evolving process and
you know it's not something which is
basically complete you know i i will do
whatever i whatever i can it
it amazes me that we have you know we
haven't got a single complainer from
average
you know which is way way closer you
know and and you know
after 30 years i've pissed off quite a
few people in aperture
uh you know they don't particularly you
know uh of the thick you know things
that we've done
when we put in a ride or you know um you
know we have we have traffic or we have
you know our bonfire nights are you know
really busy and
you know people that you know like to
park because they want to try and get
them for free so they
park all down the middle of aperture
because they want to see the fireworks
without paying you know that upsets
the locals um so you know and i'm happy
to continue working with sandy
you know and and with harvey as well you
know we've already spoken about
uh making sure that you know we liaise
about our events and his wedding so
if he's if he's having a you know a big
event there's actually no
problem if i if i can change the date or
a time or
you know you know try and try and help
then it obviously will do and i think
you know the fact that i'm prepared to
communicate with anybody
you know on a regular basis and i have
done you know i think that's the sort of
the way
you know the way forward to make sure
that you know we can happily
you know work together
thank you thank you um
okay does the panel have any questions
do you wish to ask
anybody else are we satisfied that we've
been listening
thanks there in that case then i'll take
this opportunity to retire to consider
our decision
wow all right are we ready
right there the decision
we have carefully considered this
application and the written of all
evidence of all parties presented
at the series we believe that the
relevant licensing objectives identified
in the
representations we have received um
relate to a public
prevention of public nuisance um
and our deliberations were focused on
this we believe that uh are appropriate
for the promotion of these objectives
right our concerns relate to the end
time events 10 p.m
seems reasonable seems most have
finished before
um frequency and number of events we are
mindful that this year is an exceptional
year
covered but going forward the amount
amount of
uh events we do not consider to be
reasonable um so
we're weighing the needs of all parties
the applicant is looking to recover from
the
pancake and to support other venues but
by
providing events on their behalf as they
have been
unable to operate due to
restrictions however we're also mindful
that the residents have a right
to be not to be unduly disturbed by the
events taking place on site
so
we have regard we have had regard to the
guidance issued by the home office under
section 182 of the act
to council statement of licensing policy
and
of course and
all the evidence presents to the panel
and i we have waived the needs of all
parties
so we have decided therefore to grant
the application with additional
amendments different conditions
additional conditions sorry thank you
the minimum noise level shall not exceed
the background noise levels by more than
15 decibels
over a 15 minute period
that's in the area of
influence so that is
the decision i think there was a couple
of
ones
oh sorry
oh in the future um yeah we also
consider the noise level
events and find it as reasonable to
impose a condition in line with the code
of practice
which is that it shouldn't exceed the
noise level
but this goes over ambien
you you also mentioned about the two
conditions no more than 23 days of music
event shall take place
yes okay and then one for next year as
well yep
so this year we've decided that the 23
events
would be reasonable as an exceptional
year
but going forward that wouldn't be
reasonable um
so it would have to fall in line with
the code of practice which is
a maximum of 12 events per year
soon let's clarify the wording so
for those two additional conditions
normal the 23 days of music events shall
take place during the calendar year 2021
and then going forwards no more than 12
days of music eventually take place
during the coming of the year 2022
onwards
thank you but i'm
yes
so any party may appeal against the
decision to the magistrates court within
21 days of this hearing thank you all
for attending
i'm now causing closing